class -- In the last we
lecture traditionally
we bring in a guest
lecturer to tell us
of their perspective
on complex systems
and it is with great pleasure
to welcome Hal Albelson.
A professor here at MIT
for many years, some of you
might have already
taken classes from him.
And what he is going
to talk about is
a topic we've touched upon,
but not in particular detail,
in the first two lectures.
In particular the interaction of
technology and complex systems
with law and social issues.
Hal: Ok, thanks.
Okay hi.
Hari asked me to talk about
complex systems, which
is kind of what you've
been studying all semester.
Today I want to
give you of a hint
of another kind of complexity.
You have been doing the
technical infrastructure
for essentially what has
become the information age.
But the information age...
You gotta turn off the mic.
But the information age has
just changed the world immensely
over the last 20 years
and has run smack
into another kind of complexity.
And that's the complexity of
how the stuff that we have all
built as computer scientists
and engineers has created
these enormous stressors
in the way people
think about the legal structures
and the regulatory structures,
the way people deal
with the world.
And why would you guys know, from
being a source of it,
know that it's a problem?
But in order to make use of that...
you have to understand that
suddenly you're dealing with
the real world.
It's not just problem sets
or it's not just little
theoretical issues of protocols
or how authorization works.
It is real impact
on people's lives.
And you run into people
who think differently.
And, in particular,
you are going
to have to learn to think
about how lawmakers and the law
and lots of other
institutions deal with this.
This lecture, if
you like, is partly
a bit of an advertisement
for 6.805 which, of course,
I teach in the fall.
And what 6.805 really is
about is empowering you.
What you have to understand
is by having taken
the courses you taken
like 6.033, you now
know more about the
information architecture
that makes the world work.
And all but the most minuscule
part of humanity.
And that can be a
way to have impact,
but only if you understand
how that impacts
the regulatory structure.
Just to give you a tiny example,
about two weeks ago the MBTA
put out for comments, their
new privacy policy which
was stimulated by the fact
that the MBTA is planning
on instituting a new fare
system that uses RFID tokens.
And one of the things
that went into that policy
is a whole bunch of criticism by
a student project team in 6.805
last fall who worked with
the state senator who
was getting on the MBTA's
case about not having
adequate privacy regulations.
So this bunch of MIT
students essentially
wrote the privacy
regulations that
are now being sent
out to the public
in the State of Massachusetts.
That's a tiny example
of the kind of thing
that you are now prepared to
do better than almost anybody
else in the world.
What I am going to
talk about today
is how these new architectures,
the ones you've been studying,
as you've already
seen, what happens
when you have a big
complex architecture,
you have to think about
interactions of protocols
and their standards and
their enormous unintended
consequences of things
fitting together.
That's what you've been doing,
for lots of the semester,
is using understanding that.
But today I want to
talk a little bit
about how the same thing happens
with the legal architecture.
There are protocols,
there are standards
and there are enormous,
enormous unintended consequences
of people working on different
parts of a complex system.
Well, I am not going to
talk about privacy today.
That is a thing that
the fall course does.
Today I want to talk about
regulating speech, you know,
speech, images, sounds,
the way that society
thinks about that
and sort of the mess
that the Internet has
created around that.
And so we can take like
the simplest picture.
There is the Internet and
there is a source some place
and there is a
destination some place
and then there is this cloud
that is the Internet that they
are communicating with.
And that is the stupidest
simplest picture.
You guys know infinitely
more about this picture.
Just to unpeel the very
first level of that.
You know that both the source
and destination are probably
connected to the Net using
an Internet service provider.
And then, of course,
inside that cloud
that is all sorts of stuff.
There are Cisco switched
and hubs and phone companies
and all sorts of
things translating.
You can fill out the complexity
of that picture right now,
but let's stay even
at the simple one.
Suppose something
is happening there
that somebody doesn't like.
Somebody is downloading
copyrighted music or something
and the recording
industry hates that.
Somebody is sending threatening
letters to somebody else.
Somebody is doing
gambling at a place where
you're not supposed to gamble.
Something that
somebody doesn't like.
And let's think
about we, society,
would like to figure out how you
can stop that or make it happen
less by imposing regulation.
And the question is in
any of these transactions
there are all sorts of places
that you can impose regulation.
You can go to the source
and you can say, hey,
stop sending that pornography.
You could go to the
destination and you
would say, hey, stop pulling
down that copyrighted music.
You could go to the ISPs.
I am sure nobody here has
ever downloaded copyrighted
music over the Internet.
But you can imagine the RIAA
going to MIT and saying, hey,
MIT, you are the ISP
for this connection,
you put a stop to it.
You can even imagine
somebody going to the cloud.
You can imagine congress
passing a regulation,
or maybe you can imagine it, but
unfortunately a lot of congress
can imagine passing a regulation
that says something like, hey,
let's change those Cisco routers
so that they won't pass along
copyrighted information
without permission.
And everybody
here, hopefully you
are shrinking in
horror because you
know about things like
the end-to-end principle,
and you say oh, my
God, that violates
the end-to-to principle in
a horrible, horrible way.
But you don't think
people in congress
know about the
end-to-end principle.
They need people like you
guys to explain it to them.
That is the kind of thing that
you can become empowered to do.
Within that context, let's
think about controlling
what people can say and how
people can express themselves
in words or music or
images or whatever.
Somebody comes
down and says, hey,
stop doing that, you really
shouldn't post that thing,
it is bugging somebody to hell.
And you say oh, no, because
I've got freedom of speech.
Let's look at freedom of speech.
Where does freedom of speech
come from in this country?
The First Amendment.
This country has
the First Amendment.
Congress shall make no law
respecting the establishment
of religion, or abridging the
freedom of speech, dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot.
So let's spend a little
bit thinking about that.
What does it mean when it says
congress shall make no law?
Who is Congress?
Congress is congress.
Who else is restricted
by the First Amendment?
Is the State of
Massachusetts congress?
When the State of
Massachusetts passes
a law that says you may
not post this certain kind
of information, you may not
post harassing information
on the Internet, well,
let me be more precise,
could they do it within
the confines of the First
Amendment?
We know that
congress is congress.
How about the State
of Massachusetts,
are they congress?
It actually turns out the
State of Massachusetts
is congress for the
First Amendment.
The Constitution is
the law of the land.
The Constitution
says what it says.
It says congress cannot do it.
And the Supreme Court
has interpreted congress
to mean the State
of Massachusetts.
How about if the City of
Cambridge passes a law that
says you cannot send
these kinds of things?
Well, it turns out the
City of Cambridge is, too.
It turns out the First Amendment
covers most governmental things
in the US.
How about MIT?
Could MIT, for example,
have a rule that says that?
Can there be an MIT
regulation that says that?
How many people
think there could be?
And, by could, I mean without
violating the Constitution.
How many people think
MIT could do that?
How many people
think MIT cannot?
You go and take them to court
and say it is unconstitutional.
How about UMass Boston?
Could UMass Boston
have a regulation
like that without violating
the First Amendment?
What do you think?
How many people think it could?
How many people
think it couldn't?
How many people have no idea?
Well, sort of have no
idea is the right answer.
But it kind of turns out that
this language actually comes
exactly from a policy at
the University of Michigan
ten years ago which was
struck down by the court.
That was, whatever we call
these things, harassment policy
or something.
That was actually struck
down by the court.
And what the judge said was,
look, this might be a good idea
and we might like it,
but in this country
government institutions
like by extension
of the State of Michigan and
the University of Michigan
are constrained by
the First Amendment.
MIT is not.
We can argue whether or
not it is a good idea,
but it is not unconstitutional
for MIT to do that.
Now, you might ask
do you guys have
less solid guarantees
of freedom of speech
than students at UMass Boston?
Well, yeah, probably.
There are lots of
things that congress,
and by the extension of
congress, cannot prohibit.
But what are some things
that congress can prohibit?
What are some kinds of speech
or images or things that you
actually can have laws against?
What do you think?
Are there any limits
to this at all?
What do you think?
Is there any kind of thing
that you have limits?
Student: Yelling fire in a public theater.
Student: Something that is
truly very dangerous.
This is about speech.
This is not about actions.
Are there kinds of speech
or images of things?
Child pornography.
We cannot actually possess child
pornography in this country.
We will get back to
that in a second.
Anything that can be defined
as interstate commerce?
No, that just means you
cannot reregulate it.
I am asking what are some
examples of stuff you cannot
post on the Internet.
Libel or slander.
There is a whole bit of
that copyright infringement
we talk about.
How about pornography?
You get in trouble for posting
pornography on the Internet.
Can that be prohibited
under state law?
It turns out it depends what
you mean by pornography.
In fact, if we
sort of elevate up
from pornography to
what is normally called,
you know, pornography
is bad, but really bad.
The word for really bad
in US law is obscenity.
And it turns out, well,
let's see if you know.
Do you think there is a
legal definition of obscenity
or is it like hey, it
is really bad stuff?
How many think there is a
formal legal definition when
the court looks at something
and says it is obscene?
And how many think it is
like really bad stuff?
The first people are right.
There actually is,
in this country,
a legal definition of obscenity
which was established in a case
called Miller v.
California in the `70s.
And it says this is the
definition of obscenity
according to the law.
It is called the Miller Test.
It says something is
obscene if it satisfied all
of the following three things.
A three have to be true.
The first one is that it
depicts sexual activity
in a patently offensive way.
So like it is not
an anatomy book.
That is sort about
what the stuff is.
The second one is how
people react to it.
It is a very interesting test.
It says would the average person
applying contemporary community
standards find that that appeals
to the prurient interest?
It is sort of saying it is
not the extreme guys that
are really sensitive
and it is not
the guys who will just
tolerate everything.
It is the average person
applying contemporary community
standards.
And then the third one is,
what people used to say,
utterly devoid of any
scientific, literary, artistic
or political value.
That is sometimes called
the Slap Test in law.
So there is a thing
called obscenity.
And, according to the
law, the Supreme Court,
actually in the Miller case,
found it constitutional
for there to be laws against
transmitting obscene material,
and somebody said it,
before interstate commerce.
So interstate commerce
is not prohibited
but it is the hook by which
you can prohibit something.
So it is 1994 and Robert
and Carlene Thomas
have a cute little
family business
in Milpitas, California.
And what they do is run a
thing called the Amateur Action
Bulletin Board system.
Back before we had
Internet and ISPs,
people had these bulletin
boards you would dial up.
They ran the Amateur Action
Bulletin Board system.
And they distributed
from that, well,
stuff that you wouldn't show
around in polite company.
In fact, their logo
was we are the nastiest
place on earth in 1994.
Well, two years
ago, 1992, they got
raided by the Milpitas
police who said, God,
you've got all this smut around.
We are going to close you down.
They protested.
The police looked at it and
said, well, it is bad stuff
but it is not obscene by
the standards of Milpitas,
California, we will
leave you alone.
Now we are back in 1994.
There is a knock on
the door and in come
the Milpitas police accompanied
by the US Postal Inspectors.
And Robert and
Carlene are accused
of transmitting
obscene material using
a means of interstate
communication, namely
a computer and a modem
and a phone line,
to transmit obscene
materials interstate.
And they are accused of
transmitting them interstate
to David Deremer.
Who is David Deremer?
They don't know who this guy is.
It turns out that David
Deremer is a postal inspector
in Memphis, Tennessee.
And he gets a complaint from
somebody in Western, Tennessee
saying there is this awful
smut on the Internet,
can't the US Postal Authority
do anything about it?
He takes his
computer and dials up
Welcome to Amateur Action
Bulletin Board, the nastiest
place on earth, and here are
some titillating little pieces
of stuff that you
can get from us.
But, if you really want the
good stuff, send in $55,
register and join.
He sends in his phone number,
addressed and an assumed name
with his $55.
A couple days later
he gets a call
from Robert Thomas saying hi,
thanks for your $55 bucks.
Here is your password,
good to town,
have fun, welcome to the
nastiest place on earth.
So he downloads
some stuff and then
files a complaint against them
because of this transmission
of this material interstate
from Milpitas, California
to Memphis, Tennessee.
The police come, they
arrest the Thomas's,
they impound all
their stuff and go
on trial before a jury
in Memphis, Tennessee
which convicts them of
transmitting material that
is obscene by the community
standards of Memphis,
Tennessee, which are
different from the community
standards of
Milpitas, California.
So what do you think of that?
Do you think that is OK?
Student: I think it should have been judged
by [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
You think it should go by
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], right?
Who standards should this follow?
Is this Tennessee ? Is this...?
What do you think?
Student: It is similar to
what happens if
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Hal: Right, so that's the question.
If you go and commit an atrocity
in another country, right?
Is Thomas in Tennessee
or is he in California,
that is the question.
He appeals. They appeal their
conviction and they lose.
And the judge
basically says, well,
I don't quite want
to decide this,
but notice dumdum that you
had the guy's phone number
so you knew where he
was when you called him.
So you should have been
aware that this stuff was
going to Memphis, Tennessee.
Three years in jail under that.
Let's move away from pornography
or obscenity for a minute.
Here is another thing
that is illegal.
It is illegal to
traffic in that stuff.
It is illegal to traffic
in that stuff, that
is Hitler's something birthday
commemorative stamp, in France.
It is OK in the US,
but in France it
is illegal to traffic
a Nazi memorabilia.
And in 2000, this is
on the Yahoo Auction,
actually this page isn't up
anymore, some people in France
filed a lawsuit against Yahoo
for allowing people in France
to connect to Yahoo in the US
and order Nazi memorabilia.
And that case...
You might want to compare that
with the Amateur Action Case,
but that case is still going on.
It has gone back and forth.
It is widely
complicated because it
involves international law and
French courts and US courts.
It is still going on since 2000.
There is an article that
came out two weeks ago
that talks about this case being
argued in front of the Ninth
Circuit in California.
Enormously complex
stuff because what
does this stuff mean in a world
where distance is meaningless?
I mean you guys know there are
McDonald's in Missouri where
you drive up to this window
and you put in your order
and there is a camera and
you say what your order is.
And then you drive around
and you pick up your stuff
at the kitchen.
There are McDonald's in Missouri
where that transaction from you
ordering it goes to a
McDonald's call center
in Colorado which
pieces the thing
together, sends it back to
the kitchen at the McDonald's
you are at in Missouri.
And, by the time you drive
around the McDonald's
to pick this thing up,
your order is ready.
And, because this call
center in Colorado
does a whole bunch of them and
has people who are trained,
it is cheaper for
McDonald's and faster
to route this
transaction from Missouri
to Colorado in the time you
are driving around the building
than it would be if they ran
the thing through the kitchen.
You have to ask, in
a world like that,
that's the world that we are
all making with the Internet.
And what do these laws mean?
That is a little
bit about obscenity
and contemporary standards.
In 1995, most people
in this country
were barely aware that
there was an Internet.
And the way most
people in the country
learned in 1995 that
there was a thing
called the Internet
was this way.
That is Time Magazine
from July 1995.
You guys think it is funny.
Time Magazine teaching
people about the Internet.
Sex is everywhere these days,
in books, magazines, films,
television, music videos
and bus stop perfume ads.
Americans have become so
endured to the open display
of eroticism and the
arguments for why
it enjoys special status
under the First Amendment
that they hardly
notice it is there.
But something about
the combination
of sex and computers seems
to make otherwise worldly
wide adults a little crazy.
And if you think
things are crazy now,
still quoting from
the article in 1995,
wait until the politicians get
hold of a report coming out
this week.
A research team at
Carnegie Mellon University
has conducted an exhaustive
study of online porn.
Who is downloading it?
What turns them on?
And feelings are
sure to pour out.
And, low and behold, published
a study about online porn
where they carefully
studied the habits
of average Americans,
who I think
were CMU undergraduates,
using Usenet.
And they found out
interesting conclusions.
One is they found out that
Robert and Carlene were
actually doing really well.
They were pulling in
over $1 million a year
in their business
out in Milpitas.
And the other is 83.5% of
all images posted on Usenet
are pornographic.
June 26, 1995, Senator
Charles Grassley,
who is still in the
senate, right up
on the floor of the senate, Mr.
President, there is an
article from Time Magazine
and an article that I
ask unanimous consent
to have printed in the
Congressional Record.
Mr.
President, this
morning I want to speak
on a topic that has received
a lot of attention around here
lately.
My topic is cyber porn.
Mr.
President, Georgetown University
has released a remarkable study
conducted by researchers of
Carnegie Mellon University.
This study raised
important questions
about the availability and
the nature of cyber porn.
The University surveyed
900,000 computer images.
Of these 900,000, 83.5% of
all computerized photographs
available on the Internet
are pornographic.
I want to repeat that, 83.5%,
these are all on the Internet
and are pornographic according
to the Carnegie Mellon study.
I believe congress
must act and do so
in a constitutional manner
to help parents who are
under assault this day and age.
There is a flood
of vile pornography
and we must act now to
stem the growing tide.
And, indeed, congress acted and
passed a law the Communications
Decency Act.
Which basically said
that anybody who...
You want to look at
the words of this,
they are quite
important
who makes available
to someone
under the age 18 years
things that are patently
offensive measured by
contemporary community
standards, dot, dot,
dot, or allows -- knowingly
allows a telecommunications
facility to be used
for that purpose shall
be fined under title 18
or imprisoned for not
more than two years.
It's called the
Display Provision
of the Communications
Decency Act passed into law
at the beginning of 1996.
And notice what it is doing
in terms of our picture.
It is saying there is
bad stuff going on.
Who can get hammered?
The person sending it?
The ISP who knowingly
makes that stuff available?
Cisco who is
building the routers?
Maybe.
This became part of US law.
They also added another thing
that was kind of interesting.
They added a thing
called the Good Samaritan
Provision of the Act
which says nobody
who is an ISP, that was to
help these poor guys who were
feeling very nervous, nobody
who is an ISP shall be treated
as the publisher of bad
stuff if the information came
from somewhere else.
And I will come back
to that in a minute.
Why did they add that?
Well, it is 1990 and
there is a bulletin board
system called CompuServe.
Is CompuServe still around?
Does anybody know?
It got bought by AOL?
CompuServe was one
of the early ones.
And CompuServe had
a bunch of B boards.
And they had a thing called
Rumorville or someone was using
CompuServe to post a thing
called Rumorville which was
part of their journalism forum.
Another guy named Robert
Blanchard starts up
another online publication
called Scuttlebutt,
and it was designed to
compete with Rumorville.
Rumorville then
starts publishing
defamatory statements about
Blanchard and Scuttlebutt.
The whole this is a scam.
They are no good.
They rip off their stories by
copying them from Rumorville,
dot, dot, dot.
And Blanchard goes
and sues CompuServe.
You guys are letting
this stuff happen.
It is hurting my business.
Now, what is he suing them for?
He is suing them under
a law called defamation.
Another little piece of law.
This is another thing that
you can get in trouble for.
Defamation is something, again,
all three things, is false,
you communicate to somebody
else and causes damage.
There are two kinds
of defamation.
There is the stuff that you say
which is slander and the stuff
that you write that is libel.
So Blanchard goes and sues
CompuServe for defamation.
And it is one of the basic first
rulings on Internet defamation
law, Cubby v.
CompuServe.
The judge basically says
tough, CompuServe is just
like a bookstore and they
have some books there
and they don't really know
what is in those books.
You cannot really hammer them
for what is in their books.
They neither knew
nor had any reason
to know what was in that stuff.
Go sue Rumorville but
CompuServe is off the hook.
In terms of our
picture of regulation,
the court is saying for
defamation it is that.
What is it?
Question? [unintelligible]
Student: Why didn't they consider the
destination [unintelligible]
Hal: Well, there are some
poor innocent people.
You.
You're sitting there, you're
logged into CompuServe,
you read some awful
thing about Rumorville,
she is supposed to
get hammered for that?
Yeah, this is
other people who are just sort
of knowing that the source was
coming from there.
That was 1990, five years later.
Five years later the
Internet is growing.
There is concern
about pornography.
It is not only the uber geeks
who were using CompuServe,
there was a company
called Prodigy.
Prodigy still exists.
Prodigy was a bulletin board.
They advertised themselves
as a family friendly service.
Hi, guys, there
is this Internet.
You can join Prodigy.
It is kind of safe
for your kids.
And the way they did that
is they had chat rooms
and hired people to
moderate their chat rooms,
and if any bad stuff happened
the moderator would cut it off.
So Prodigy is running the
family-oriented B board
service.
And there is a company that
is an investment banking
place called Stratton-Oakmont
and they are about to
make a new offering.
And somebody on one of the
Prodigy bulletin boards
starts publishing stuff
about Stratton-Oakmont.
They don't know who
this somebody is.
It is anonymous.
But Stratton-Oakmont is
a bunch of crooks.
The president was in jail.
This offering they are
going to do is a fraud.
And Stratton-Oakmont
goes and sues Prodigy
because whoever was
posting it was anonymous.
They go sue Prodigy, and
Prodigy says hey, guys,
we went through this.
This is Cubby v.
CompuServe all over again.
Go find the people who are
doing it, get on their backs,
we are clean.
And the New York State
Court of Appeals say uh-uh,
you're not the same because
you are moderating those chat
rooms.
You are taking responsibility
for what is being said there.
Therefore, you have
liability because you
are doing the moderation.
You, in fact, are libel as
the publisher of that stuff
because you are controlling it.
It is quite comforting
for freedom of speech
to let ISPs get off the hook.
In response to this,
every university lawyer
at any place that
had an Internet
went to the
administration and said
hey, guys, don't control
what the students are doing.
Whatever you do don't control
it because, as soon as you do,
you are liable.
It certainly happened at MIT,
and I assume very place else.
But what is it doing in
terms of our picture here?
Our poor ISPs who
were off the hook
now get targeted
in a way big-time.
Coming back to the
Communications Decency Act,
why was there that Good
Samaritan Provision?
Well, congress was sitting
there saying well, gee, not only
do we want to regulate
pornography and stop that
but we really would like
the ISPs to help us.
We would like them to
filter this stuff out.
So it is the policy, and
this is part of the law,
of the US that there
should be filtering.
And we want to encourage parents
and ISPs and everybody to keep
this smut off the network.
On the other hand, that
was right after the Prodigy
decision.
And all the ISPs said
hey, wait a minute,
that's not going to work.
So they passed this
Good Samaritan Provision
which was trying to let
them get off the hook.
It is actually a little bit
more complicated than that
because this had to do with the
republicans and the democrats
and stuff that got worked out
in committee and different bills
of which pieces were taken from
other bills and put together.
Winston Churchill
once said that anyone
who likes sausages or law
should never watch either
of them being made.
And the Communications Decency
Act is a little bit like that.
Well, the law got
passed in February 1996.
The whole civil liberties
were all going nuts.
Everybody who was looking
at Internet law went nuts.
If you take 6.805
there is a long story
about what eventually turned out
to be a major, major decision
in First Amendment law,
which I won't go into here,
but the net result was
the Supreme Court decided
that the Display Provision of
the Communications Decency Act
was unconstitutional.
Right, and they said...
they said why? The community
standards are too broad.
If you apply that it means
the standard of the most
restrictive community
will start replying
across the whole country.
And it turns out
the government can
pass laws to protect
kids access to stuff,
but they say in this case, by
this desire to protect kids,
you are restricting
adults from what
they should be able to get.
Anyway, a long, very, very
important First Amendment
decision, Reno v. ACLU.
The Supreme Court ruling came
down and everybody was happy,
civil liberty groups,
everybody jumped up and down
and said the Internet is a zone
of free speech, which brings us
to Ken.
We are back in 1995.
It is April 19, 1995.
We just went through
the tenth anniversary
of a really horrible
thing in US history.
Does anybody know what it is,
almost exactly ten years ago?
The bombing of the courthouse in
Oklahoma City, April 19, 1995.
I guess you guys remember that.
About a week later
appears on AOL
an announcement that says hey,
naughty Oklahoma t-shirts,
visit Oklahoma, it's
a blast and lots
of cruder things about
referring to the kids who
had been killed in that
bombing and all sorts of stuff.
Visit Oklahoma, it's a blast,
call Ken for naughty Oklahoma
t-shirts.
And there in the message
is the phone number
of Ken Zeran who is just a
guy who lives in Seattle.
Well, lots of people call Ken.
They call him angry and upset
with obscene phone calls,
threatening phone calls.
He says he doesn't know
anything about this.
What the hell are you doing?
They tell him about
this thing he did.
How could you possibly
do that, you bastard?
So he calls AOL and says come
on, I didn't put this up.
It has this stuff that
has got my name on it.
Take it down and
publish a retraction.
Mr.
Zeran, we sort of have
to look into this.
And you have to understand
that we don't actually
know who had this account
because they are anonymous.
And it is not our policy
to publish retractions,
but we will sort of do it.
And maybe we will turn off
the account and check into it.
The next day more slogans.
Naughty Oklahoma,
we have t-shirts,
we have bumper stickers.
Visit Oklahoma, it's
a blast, call Ken.
And, by the way, there is a
real demand for these things
so if you call and the line is
busy make sure you call back.
By April 30th Ken Zeran is
getting an abusive phone call
every two minutes.
May 1st, KXRA, a local
Oklahoma radio station
says you know what is
going on in Seattle?
There is this guy who is
publishing stuff selling
t-shirts making fun of our
kids who died in the blast
two weeks ago.
His name is Ken Zeran.
Why don't you tell him
what you think about him?
Here is phone number.
Here is his address.
The police are guarding
Zeran's house now.
Well, Zeran finally
gets in touch with KXRA
and they publish
the announcement
that it is a mistake.
They broadcast a
retraction of that.
And by the end of May
Zeran is down to only 15
threatening phone calls a day.
So over the next months he
gets a lawyer and sues AOL.
He says you guys are negligent.
I called you about this
thing, it was causing me harm,
it was on your thing,
you did not take action,
it took a real long time for
them to shut off these accounts
and you guys are
guilty of negligence.
And AOL's lawyers go hey, hey.
The Supreme Court...
Well actually, the law hadn't
been struck down by then.
They go hey, hey hey.
Look at this provision that
congress has passed into law.
I don't care what
you said we did.
We didn't provide
that information.
We have no liability for it.
And the court agrees with them.
And it turns out, by the way,
that when congress struck down
the Communications Decency Act,
they struck down that Display
Provision.
But there is nothing
unconstitutional about that.
You can argue whether or
not it is a good idea,
but there is nothing
unconstitutional about it.
This thing is still
part of US law.
You had a question.
Student: [unintelligible]
...1996.
Hal: What was it? Was it struck down?
Student: The one with the lawsuit...
Hal: The lawsuit was actually
at the beginning of '96.
It sort of went through
this whole thing.
It took him...
I think it was the
beginning of 1996
because there was
a lot of arguing
going back and forth with
AOL between when it was done.
It took several months.
So AOL says I don't care if
we are negligent, we are free.
It is not our problem.
It gets worse.
2001, Jane Doe, in
an anonymous lawsuit,
sues AOL on behalf of her
teenage son, John Doe.
It is anonymous.
They are protecting him
because he is a minor.
And she is suing AOL.
She lives in Florida.
It turns out there was a guy
named Richard Russell, who
by that time was
in prison, as you
will see for
obvious reasons, who
advertised on AOL to find kids
who would come to his house.
And he filmed them
in pornographic acts,
including Jane
Doe's son, John Doe.
And sold this stuff over
the Internet on AOL.
Jane Doe sues AOL,
you guys are making
money from trafficking
in child pornography,
in pornographic
pictures of my son.
Now we're talking
child pornography.
AOL says hey, hey, the Good
Samaritan Provision, title 19,
section 230, we are not liable.
This is 2001.
This bounced around in the
courts for about three years
and finally went to the
Florida Supreme Court.
And the Florida Supreme
Court agreed with AOL.
It ain't the greatest thing man,
but that is what the law says,
you are not liable as
an ISP if you are not
the provider of
that information.
That is a two to one decision
in the Florida Supreme Court.
The minority opinion by Judge
Lewis, the guy just went ape.
He said this is nuts.
How could it conceivably have
been the intent of congress,
in a law that was motivated
by protecting kids
from pornography
on the Internet.
How could it conceivably been
the intent of congress
that a consequence
of that law is now
that somebody who is
trafficking in child pornography
is actually immunized?
But that is the current
state of the world.
And you see what it comes from.
It comes from looking at
this very complex system
of regulations and the
interaction between First
Amendment Law and
defamation law and the fact
that you can apply regulations.
You want to partly
immunize those ISPs,
but you don't want
to let them off free.
And you end up with
exactly the same kinds
of unintended consequences
that happen whenever you
monkey with any complex system.
It is not a whole lot different
from the kind of stuff
you have seen on
the technology side
when you are talking about
how the technical base
of the Internet works.
So where does that leave us?
Well, I guess in
terms of the law,
it kind of leaves us there in
a very, very confused state.
And getting more
and more confused
because what has
happened recently,
this whole thing is now
mixed in international law.
If you go search
on Google for stuff
from the Taiwan
Ministry of Defense
you will find that in the US.
Will you find it in China?
No.
Google China has a
different search.
Will you find it
if you somehow are
able to log into US
Google from Beijing?
Yeah, you would see it.
What kind of liability is there?
You're personal liability
with the Chinese government,
is it Google who is going to
get hammered in their trade
agreements in terms of China?
We don't know.
What is going to happen
with France and Yahoo?
This whole picture has
become even much, much
more complex as a consequence
of all of us engineers making
this Internet which
has effectively
made distance vanish.
So where does that leave us?
It leaves us with you, I
guess, and where I started.
You guys have
enormous power that
comes from the stuff you
have learned in this course.
You have the ability to
go out and really, really
influence the world
by making stuff,
by explaining to people
stuff they don't know,
like the end-to-end
principal is one.
And it is really a
question of would you
like to grab that power
and take advantage of it?
But, in order to
do that, you need
to understand this other
piece of the world.
OK.
Thank you.